ja ich begrüße sie zur letzten sitzung
in diesem semester in dem wir in der wir
uns mit einer ganz zentralen position
beschäftigen werden nämlich mit der
position dieses netten herrn hier
sie ahnen alle wäre es ist das ist
natürlich aristoteles nicht das ist
natürlich schon meckert der einen ganz
langen namen hat das ist glaube ich so
schottischen ursprungs können sie mal
bei wikipedia nachschauen
die haben da immer so stammes
bezeichnung dort oben
und die haben also ganz langen armen und
wir wollen uns jetzt hier mit einem
aufsatz von diesem netten herren hier
befassen der mit dem titel die an
reality of time trägt und der in der
recht bekannten zeitschrift meint
erschien ist vor über 110 jahren
und wenn sie mal auf die geburts und
sterbedaten dieses herrn schauen dann
sehen sie dass der eigentlich in unserer
reihenfolge die wir uns hier
chronologisch vorgenommen haben diesem
semester dass er eigentlich nicht an
letzter stelle stehen sollte
das sind an vorletzter stelle weil
martin heidegger im jahr 1889 geboren
ist also jünger ist und natürlich auch
viel später verstorben ist in den 70ern
also herr martin haidinger ist
chronologisch gesehen in der zeit stimmt
uns eigentlich mehr aber vom zugang und
von der art der rezeption folgt
mctaggart einer anderen linie oder
richtung nämlich man könnte schon sagen
dass mit ihm die analytische philosophie
der zeit beginnt
sicherlich gehört in die analytischen
philosophie derzeit auch ihr aristoteles
hinein und man kann so zwei gruppe
ansätze unterscheiden das möchte ich
jetzt einfach mal hier versuchen dass
wir jetzt zum schluss dieser sitze
ein bisschen klassifizieren dass wir uns
einen überblick verschaffen über die
verschiedenen zugangsweisen zu dieser
sehr komplexen thematik es gibt eben
einmal die fahrt die art von
phänomenologie der zeit die
phänomenologie der zeit das heißt als
man fast die zeit als ein subjektives
phänomen auf was an dauerhaft also zeit
bewusst sein feld darunter also zeit
bewusst seine zeit empfinden das
eigentlich dasselbe dann qualitäten
derzeit derzeit also so eine
beschreibung wie wir sie zb bei onkel
berg so gesehen haben die würde ich
jetzt als phänomenologie derzeit
beschreiben
obwohl der song gar nicht als ein
viertel logik gilt wenn sie als immer
auf wikipedia schauen man sich
informieren
dann wird der als ein lebensphilosophie
klassifiziert verdient der begriff des
lebens im zentrum steht
wie auch immer der phänomenologie möchte
ich da mal unterscheiden
das ist einfach so was dass man diese
subjektive qualität subjektiv ich das
ist jetzt nicht das jetzt geht einander
überall die subjektive qualität
zeit dass man sagt die dauer ver ist so
beschaffen so strukturiert dass dauer
empfinden dann gibt es so eine art von
analytischer und sie sehen schon worauf
das hinausläuft kann natürlich nicht
ganz klar abgrenzen aber sie werden
sehen dass die phänomenologie der zeit
er sich mit der nach matt eckert
genannten von mit sogenannten
beschäftigt und die analytische
philosophie derzeit eher mit der reihe
also hier geht es dann eher um
zb um logische probleme wie zb die frage
wie kann überhaupt ein wechsel
stattfinden wie können wir uns überhaupt
ein wechsel in der zeit vor steuern also
veränderung veränderung nicht
veränderung und dem subjekt um die
gesichtspunkt des subjektiven empfindens
sind einfach logik der zeit
das würde ich jetzt als analytische und
analytischen zugang bezeichnen denn zahl
und zeit
das war bei aristoteles sondern sich
noch und das ist natürlich klar dass
hier hier so weit wie die beiden ins
spiel kommt vielleicht sogar auch eine
cd die wir heute bei mctaggart noch
kennenlernen werden und ich möchte auch
noch ein drittes einen dritten punkt ein
dritter dritten zugang zur zeit
unterscheiden nämlich die ontologie der
zeit
hier geht es also um den ganzen
zusammenhang zeit im zusammenhang
gewählt raimund zeit und sie sehen schon
dass den albert einstein würde ich ihr
in die ontologie derzeit kopieren
er fragt also wie sieht die zeit zum
ganzen verhält seit dem zusammenhang
nämlich das albert einstein würde ich
hier rein nehmen im raum und zeit und
auch den schelling würde ich tendenziell
hier rein toning theologie derzeit aber
man könnte ihn auch schon tendenziell
ihrer nehmen aber im training würde ich
ihr hier rein tun also dass das das welt
ganze die welt alter allein schon der
titel wild alter sind metaphysische und
logische überlegung das kann man sich
natürlich überlegen wo kommt jetzt unser
herr kant rein der immanuel kant was
würden sie sagen sie müssen jetzt ja
auch nicht eindeutig einen kopierer wo
würden sie ihn am ehesten unterbringen
immanuel kants theorie ja
ja ich denke auch hier oder hier weil er
andererseits sehr scharf sind als er hat
sich immer auch mit dem raum beschäftigt
aber er hat dann erinnern sich die zeit
auch analytisch vom als reine
anschauungs form differenziert und
freigelegt und das würde ich sagen dass
wir so eine geschichte der analytischen
philosophie
also kann würde ich hier so dazwischen
nehmen schelling würde ich sagen er mehr
auf die anthologie derzeit liegen oder
dann eher tendenziell hierhin und ich
glaube diese drei zugriffe sind recht
prominent im augustinus würde ich wenn
ihr zwischen analytische philosophie und
phänomenologie nehmen und so können wir
uns jetzt für jeden das überlegen den
leibniz zb würde ich auch hier zwischen
theologie und analytische philosophie
nehmen vielleicht noch mehr auf die
seite der ontologie dass ich auch sehr
mit dem zusammenhang von raum und zeit
beschäftigt hat aristoteles würde ich
auch hier die mitte nehmen ihr ein
bisschen mehr analytische philosophie
der zeit und so weiter und so fort also
das sind zwei ganz gruppe
kategorisierung möglichkeiten unserer
philosophie die wir hier in diesem
semester gesprochen haben und noch
besprechen
und jetzt wollen wir auf die leitfragen
zu sprechen kommen nämlich wie hängen a
b und c der zeit miteinander zusammen
wir haben also jetzt bei mctaggart noch
eine dritte reihe
die ins spiel kommt eine ca sie wollen
verstehen lernen was das eigentlich ist
die liefern argumentiert mctaggart für
die uhr wirklichkeit derzeit also das
ist eine große frage die man in der
philosophie immer mit den begriffen
realismus und anti realismus bezeichnet
ich müsste jetzt auf anhieb gar nicht wo
ich diese behandlung der frage unter
bringen würde vielleicht tatsächlich ihr
hier bei der analytischen philosophie
der zeit also den mctaggart würde ich
jetzt hier einem und so ein bisschen
hier eigentlich entspannter auch so ein
bisschen die ontologie aber ich würde
mir hier also tendenziell wir hier oder
so in der mitte einen also es gibt
realismus und materialismus bezüglich
der zeit also was heißt sind das anti
realismus die frage ist einfach die ist
zeit wirklich existiert sie wirklich und
wirklich bedeutet hier unabhängig von
uns als erkennenden wesen und viele
philosophen der geschichte haben gesagt
zeit ist nicht in dem sinne wirklich
objektiv als sie unabhängig von uns
existieren würde wie zb bestimmte
gegenstände in diesem raum wie dieses
schöne wollmütze hier und diese leere
glasflasche auf der verkauf ist
die existieren unabhängig von meiner
erkennenden subjektivität und anders ist
es mit der zeit bei immanuel kant zum
beispiel der sagt zeit ist mein rheine
anschauen es vor die mit unserer
subjektivität zu tun hat deswegen
spricht kommt auch von einem
transzendentalen idealismus als raum und
zeit sind nicht objektiv
gegenständliches gegeben sondern es sind
strukturen die die bedingung der
möglichkeit von objektivität ist
darstelle und die als solche von uns
erkennen wesen abhängig sind
also kann zum beispiel ist ein anti
realist bezüglich der zeit und auch
hegel zum beispiel ist tendenziell hand
er realistisch während man sie jetzt
fragen kann wie es bei leibnitz ist
leibnitz jahr bei leibnitz ist es ja so
sieht man sich bei leibnitz ergibt sich
die zeit erst aus einer bestimmten
ordnung heraus als auch hier ist ein
bisschen schwierig ihn zu klassifizieren
den gibt es noch schelling was würden
sie sagen dieses bei schilling ist er
ein anti real ist oder eine realistische
zeit
würde ich auch sagen ja glaubt celik ist
eine der größten realisten derzeit also
alle die mehr als also ich würde nicht
sagen alle die mehr unter logi derzeit
vertreten
in diesem realisten sein aber es gibt
eine tendenz dazu gemacht dass das er
dann objektiv gesehen wird also können
sich das mal so ein bisschen
klassifizieren also mit dieser zugangs
weise können sie immer alle positionen
noch mal revue passieren lassen und auch
mit dieser unterscheidung zwischen
realismus und andy realismus können sie
das noch mal machen
genau
das ist eine frage und eine weitere
frage
ohne das wir ist ein bisschen allgemein
gesagt die hänge nicht von strukturen
der subjektivität ab die hängen nicht
von dem empfinden ab
sie wissen
ja also wie gesagt bei kant ist es
komplizierter also kann sagt ja
letztendlich dass wir was uns selbst
anbelangt dass wir im eigentlichen sinne
zeitlose wesen sind also die zeit kommt
nur dann ins spiel wenn wir es mit
sinneserfahrung zu tun haben
deswegen stellt sich verkannt diese
frage obwohl sie sehr wichtig ist ein
sehr angebracht ist nicht wie es denn
jetzt zeitliches geben konnte als noch
nicht menschen existierten weil verkannt
es immer einen intelligenten und einen
sensiblen charakter gibt und der
intelligenter der sagen unsere vernunft
natur und die existiert unabhängige
ausserhalb gezeigt und alles was
zeitlich ist ist nur äußerlich hat sich
papiere aber jetzt noch mal zurück auf
diese flasche diese flasche lässt sich
beschreiben von ihrer art rein
physikalisch es wird ein raum punkt sie
hat besteht aus diesen teilchen die mit
bestimmten kräften zusammenhängen und da
kommt keine subjektive qualität rein und
anders ist es eben bei vielen
philosophen die sagen zeit ist entweder
nur etwas was als eine art effekt
auftritt wenn etwas schon gegeben ist
dann tritt das auf oder manche würden
sagen zeit besteht eben im empfinden von
zeitdauer von veränderung und die
subjektive empfinden von veränderungen
das nennt man eben zeit
da muss also ein subjekt dasein in der
welt dass sowas wie zeitempfinden kann
wo es keine empfundenen empfindsamen
subjekte gibt da gibt es eben nur eine
un-reform von veränderungen die jetzt
eigentlich gar nicht zeit genannt werden
kann ist natürlich immer die frage was
vor zeitbegriff man hat ne und diese
unterscheidung verschiedener zeit
begriffe die hängen jetzt ganz zentral
mit dieser unterscheidung von a b und c
zusammen
natürlich ist mctaggart jetzt nicht in
dem sinne ein anti realist der zeit als
er jetzt nur an von der subjektivität
abhängig macht aber wie wir gleich sehen
werden er wird sagen dass zeit vor allem
mit der ara zusammenhängt also mit
unserer subjektiven erfahrungen mit dem
präsent ist ischen empfinden dass die
zeit eben vergangen gegenwärtig oder
zukünftig ist und das ist für ihn die
wichtigste charakterisierung der zeit
und mit tiger wird sagen dass an dieser
charakterisierung der zeit und in dieser
karte ist derzeit ein widerspruch
enthalten ist und dass deswegen weil
eben diese vorstellung der arbeit
derzeit widersprüchlich ist eben auch
die zeit nicht objektiv wirklich
existiert und dieses argument gewinnt er
natürlich dadurch dass er sich hier mit
der subjektiven qualität der zeit als
jetzt mit dem zeitempfinden aber wenn
man uns dann wenn man sich dann zum
beispiel mal die zwei derzeit anschaut
die eine bloße ordnung ist wieso zahlen
strahlen oder die bären dann sieht man
dass das jetzt nicht mehr von einem
subjekt das zeitempfinden es abhängt und
trotzdem wird mit eckart für einen
unwirklichkeit ein anti realismus
derzeit argumentieren auch wenn die boc
republik unabhängig ist es geht jetzt
einfach nur um die form der beschreibung
und ich brauche um zur erklärung dieser
flasche brauche ich keine subjektiven
qualitäten brauche kein empfinden das
bewusstsein um diese flasche erklären zu
können und es gibt eben manche phänomene
derzeit wie zb gegenwarts empfinden
zukunfts empfinden also zeitempfinden
als zukunft als gegenwart als
vergangenheit er brauche ich eben ins
objekt diese dimension der zeit bekomme
ich nur mit einem zug der welt und die
physikalische beschreibung des der
flasche brauche ich ohne kann ich kann
ich vollkommen herstellen ohne jegliche
form von subjektivität
hat die b 3 und die zwei da brauche ich
subjektivität eigentlich nicht dazu da
ist richtig und wir wollen jetzt einfach
mal schauen wie mctaggart hier
argumentiert und wir wollen uns auch
fragen ob diese argumente überzeugend
sind wir wollen ja nicht nur beschreiben
soll nun auch bewerten und das sollen
sie auch in ihre hausarbeit und ich
werde auch noch mal eine sprechstunde
anbieten
wahrscheinlich diesen freitag ich
schicke ihnen da heute oder morgen
nochmal da sie nur darauf gefasst sind
noch mal eine e-mail rum dass sich
beantragen kann
ansonsten können sie mir das sage jetzt
als kurze zwischenbemerkung mehr
jederzeit ich bitte sie sogar darum mehr
falls sie es nicht nur eine sprechen
schaffen mir einfach wenn sie eine
hausarbeit schreiben wollen eine kuh ein
kurzes exposé schicken das heißt eine
halbe seite mit den wichtigsten fragen
und themen stellung mit denen sie sich
befassen wollen im rathaus arbeit weil
häufig ist es so
bedenken sie trotz dieses hohen niveaus
was wir hier jetzt uns zu allen gemacht
haben sie sind nur in einem bachelor
seminar bedenken sie dass die sind hier
nicht in einem oberseminar und nicht in
einem master seminar und deswegen gerade
wenn sie noch am anfang des studiums
stehen neigt man dazu sich zu viel
vorzunehmen
in einer auswahl und meine aufgabe
besteht nur darin ihnen zusagen machen
sie weniger konzentrieren sich dafür
mehr
das können sie sich eigentlich selbst
auch sagen das ist eigentlich alles was
ich ihnen in der meisten zeit sagen
würde reduzieren sie sich im stoff
machen sie keinen vergleich ja dass das
sind die meisten rückmeldung die ich
ihnen geben
konzentrieren sie sich auf ein oder zwei
fragen aber jetzt nach malaga der exkurs
zu und jetzt geht's also mitten in
diesen englischsprachigen text hinein
den ich ihnen jetzt einfach mal
hier sind den wir jetzt gemeinsam lesen
können ist der leser oder soll ich die
das tafel licht ausmachen was wollen sie
wer kann es nicht lesen
ok alle ohne tafel ist besser dann mache
ich es aus wenn ich mal an der zeit ist
dann blendet es etwas da ist der
sichtwinkel nicht sehr gut
ok jetzt geben einfach mal rein also
erfolgte die partei front national
position auf meine thesen wie oft in der
station auf die an reality of space of
die an reality of magic chapter iv ages
die believe in die an reality of time
has ruft singularity attraktiv also wir
haben es jetzt hier mit einem bekannten
phänomen zu tun nämlich dass immer
wieder in der geschichte der philosophie
die wirklichkeit die objektivität der
zeit angezweifelt wurde ja also ich habe
jetzt hier schon ein paar beispiele
genannt immanuel kant zum beispiel sagt
zeit liegt nicht gegenständlich vor
seiner zeit ist ihr die bedingung der
möglichkeit von gegenständlichkeit also
wenn wir nicht die subjektive
anschauungs form der zeit haben dann
bekommen wir auch gar keine zeit gar
kein gegenständlichkeit die wir erkennen
können also ist sagen eigentlich scheint
es sagt er hier also höchst paradox dass
sein dass man die unmöglichkeit derzeit
behauptet aber trotzdem wurde sie immer
wieder in der geschichte der philosophie
behauptet und ich habe ihn wie gesagt so
ein paar beispiele genannt
immanuel kant wäre so einer mit
sicherheit man kann sich auch überlegen
ob augustinus ein solcher er realist
derzeit ist halt jetzt sagte hier das
ist typisch der analytisch also das ist
jetzt ein analytischer stil
sie erkennen analytisches thiele daran
dass die bereits auf der ersten seite
ihre these formulieren das ist das
exakte gegenteil zum beispiel zu einem
schelling bei dem sie nie wissen am ende
was jetzt seine these ja oder wenn sie
glück haben wird er seine these ganz am
ende sagen oder irgendwo versteckt sie
müssen die these bei diesen historischen
ja auch ja kontinentalen philosophen
sage ich jetzt mal hier suchen dann
müssen sie sich anstrengen und die these
zu finden und bei ihr analytisch
geprägten philosophen da finden sie die
these explizit als solche auf der ersten
seite
das ist der unterschied ich sage jetzt
nicht dass das eine oder andere besser
ist ich sage einfach nur wie der stil
ist der argumentation also jetzt sagte
hirai believe that time ist andre ayew
so friesen switch ort als template bei
endlich auf der verfasstheit menschen
er hat nämlich zb hegel genannt the
proposed explain maurice 1 in visp
das ist also ganz typisch in diesem
paper also das ist ein paradigmatisch
analytisches paper dieser satz der ist
in den augen von möglichen gutachtern
die ja immer diese papers lesen reviews
die dann entscheiden müssen ob diese
aufsatz genommen wird oder nicht ist der
also ein klingt der ganz tollen den
ohren weil die wissen was wir sagen und
was wird er tun und in einem paper das
heißt in einem umfang von 20 bis 30
seiten und nicht wie bei schelling in
einem fragment gebliebenen riesen opus
mit 400 500 seiten wo sie am ende gar
nicht mehr wissen was gehört alles dazu
und was nicht und wo es fünf
verschiedene fassungen gibt ja dass das
nur mal so als eine art kontrast als ich
hier sehen sie geht es ganz klar die
thesen ich sage mir gesagt nicht dass
das dadurch philosophischer ist aber es
einfach anders
das hat man hat einen anderen zugang zu
diesem text positions in time
er ist ein prima fazit des think it into
the position is earlier than some and
later than some auf die ada positions
expressionistischer past present future
distinction south forma class a
permanent riders of the board bei dem
event witches neo present future and
will be passt was ist jetzt hier der
unterschied was auf welche
unterscheidung kommt jetzt hier meckert
zu sprechen
in diesem zitat um was geht es ihm jetzt
hier
alles geht es um positionen in der zeit
als wir machen jetzt hier ein haben wir
einen schönen zeit streit
ich mache jetzt mit absicht doch ich
mache jetzt ich gebe derzeit jetzt eine
richtung das muss ich schon machen
ich habe nämlich gerade gefragt ob ich
sind beiden fällen machen mussten
aber ich muss das glaube ich schon mal
an so was kann ich jetzt hier machen
ja ganz genau wir nehmen jetzt mal genau
wir nehmen jetzt mal m und in m und m
eigentlich sollte das denn darüber
machen ich weiß nicht warum es jetzt
runter gemacht habe
als wir haben ihm und so und wie nennt
er diese punkte die nennt er positionen
wissen sie wie mit helga diese punkte
noch nennt später in diesem text oder
abends in idee wie man diese punkte noch
nennen könnte
wie nimmt man zeitpunkt noch
geben sie doch noch einen anderen
begriff an oder anderes wort an dasselbe
bezeichnet wenn sie ein zeitpunkt haben
sie noch in anderen anderes wort für
zeitpunkt ja genau
kein moment ein moment im moment ist ein
zeitpunkt oder eine position innerhalb
des 2 auf dem zeitstrahl zur also jetzt
können wir eben also wie gesagt wir
können auf zwei verschiedene weisen nur
zeit punkte oder momente unterscheiden
jede position also nehmen wir zb
ml ml das macht auch meckert immer also
jede position ist früher als eine andere
und später als eine andere
position
also ist früher als und später als m
wenn wir hier keine zeit schalensitzen
stimmen sie mir damit so ist früher als
später als
und eine weitere möglichkeit ist jede
position ist entweder vergangen
gegenwärtig oder zukünftig also sagen
wir mal die gegenwart sei hier
hier seien jetzt gerade die gegenwart
dann ist natürlich dass zukünftig und
das vergangen das hängt jetzt aber davon
ab wo wir die gegenwart einzeichnen
also eben ist in allen möglichen welten
des kurdenproblems jetzt mal so in allen
möglichen welten ist im früher als eng
und in früher als in allen möglichen
welten
aber es ist eine mögliche welt ein
szenario denkbar in dem gegenwärtig ist
und demzufolge nicht mehr entgegen wert
ist sondern vergangen und im vergangen
und zwar vor vergangen
also praktisch präteritum 2 weil es noch
vor dem ende liegt was ja auch schon
vergangen ist
als distinction es auf die formel es
nämlich was wir gemacht und ist
permanent up firmen permanent meint in
allen möglichen wegen sind die ebenso in
ihrer ordnung wahllos auf die länder
anders
sie hatten sich gemeldet ja ja ab
inwiefern können sie noch ein bisschen
ja aber ja nur in relation zu einem
anderen system und er hat ja nur ein
system hier also es wäre richtig ja aber
wenn er eben es nicht sagt dann müsste
man inszenierte und theologischen
sparsamkeit einfach davon ausgehen dass
es nur ein system gibt
aber sie haben recht werden wir noch ein
anderes system hinein bringen dann sieht
es ganz anders aus da haben sie recht da
wäre dann aber trotzdem glaube ich
nichts im wesentlichen verändert worden
weil die ordnung wäre auch dieselbe wenn
auch im sinne einer anderen zeit
differenz das heißt diese unteren
beschreibung würden sich ändern aber die
ordnung lieben dieselbe die ab folgt die
logik ab wurde die bleibt dieselbe
auch in relativistischen system nur die
zeitdauer in denen die abfolgen die
verändert sich und jetzt will ich auch
endlich den punkt kommen
hier hat nämlich jetzt mctaggart eine
wichtige unterscheidung eingeführt
nämlich versucht jetzt haben der armen
der bereiter zeit in verbindung zu
bringen was ist die arbeit war dass die
bären
wir haben immer mit diesen a und b rein
operiert und ich hatte ihn ganz zu
beginn gesagt die stammen von max eckart
also wir machen das was wir eigentlich
anfang an schon getan haben hier ist die
zahl ende also womit wo handelt sich
hier um bei welcher dieser klassen
handelt es sich jetzt um die a3 und wo
vorhanden bei handelt es sich jetzt
bereit derzeit genau also da wo ich
diese pfeile immerhin machen um zu sagen
das ist gegenwart da es mit der arbeit
zu tun das ist austauschbar
falls ob jetzt en gegenwärtig ist oder
vergangen hängt einfach davon ab wann
ich als subjektivität in den zeitstrahl
trete und wo ich mich als objekt
positionieren wo ich mache also was
jetzt hier vergangen oder zukünftig ist
hängt einfach davon ab wo ich als
präsent ist subjekt mich setzen muss man
sagen ja also das was zukünftig ist
etwas vergangen ist das ist abhängig von
meinem eintreten man gegenwärtigen
eintreten in den inter zeit kontinuum
deshalb hier ist jetzt gegenwart und
daran zeigt sich was eben jetzt daran
gemessen relativ eben zukünftig und
vergangen ist und es ist die a3 und
diese ordnung
das war sagt renn ist einfach vor und
nach ihm das sind einfach fixe
relationen nicht abhängig sind von mir
als zeitempfinden subjekt
das ist also die unterscheidung von a&b
rey und er wird das jetzt noch ein
bisschen weiter ausführen wir lesen
einfach mal weiter weil er das an einer
anderen stelle explizit sagt und das ist
eine ganz wichtige unterscheidung
versagt folgendes zins des angels auf
der first class a permanent fristlos
meint jetzt nicht a sind diesmal geht es
bei weil er ja in den vorherigen hier
erst earlier dance am sagt hatte das ist
also die erste klasse und das vergangen
gegenwehr die zukunft die zweite klasse
also jetzt nicht mit a und b verwechseln
also sechs zins des dinkels und first
class nämlich jetzt hier hat steht er
ein abkommen an dem may be had to be
more than to be more is essential to the
nature of time belieferung erwartet das
wort bier mistake distinktion of past
present future ist es ist angles times
dass sich schon oft brillant leider weil
in der sensations sieg mégane ist
momentan das ding schon oft brillant
lake and this because this section of
past present future team germany ist ein
stadtteil tiergarten greer was sagt er
jetzt hier
er macht jetzt einen einwand er sagt
jetzt da sich die erste klasse nämlich
das früher und später da sich das
permanent verhält als in allen möglichen
welten unabhängig von meiner
subjektivität wann ich mich jetzt hier
einsetzen
ob ich mich jetzt hier positioniere
schon sagen ist die gegenwart dann
bleibt die falls verhältnis dasselbe
nämlich eng ist eben praktisch jünger
als m bzw
also später und früher als das ist genau
dasselbe wenn auch wenn ich mich hierhin
versetzte jetzt gegenwärtig dann gilt
genauso das m früher als ns und später
als m und in früher als später als das
ist unabhängig diese ordnung von dem
jeweiligen zeitbezug den ich hier ein
gehe wo ich mich als gegenwärtig sitzen
das verhältnis ist immer folgendes ich
mache mal hier oben hin also ist größer
als er ist größer als und praktisch ich
könnte noch sagen
am ende brauchen wir aber mal zu belegen
ist grün und damit hammers eigentlich
ja damit hammer als er damit hamas
daraus kann ich eben schließen dass das
früheste ist aus diesen zwei
beschreibungen und diese beschreibung
die gelten einfach unabhängig von meiner
subjektiven zeit erfahrung
das sind einfach objektiv verordnungen
wie auf den zahlen strahl wie ich sagen
kann ich kann genauso sagen ich sage mal
dass er jetzt hier 123 also seit 2 dann
mache ich zwei ist größer als 1 und 3
ist größer als 2 das ist einfach wahr
unabhängig von meinem zeitpunkt anders
verhält es sich wenn sie eben sagen es
sei gegenwärtig dann ist im vergangen
das machen wir wir machen jetzt hier
oben hat man alle beschreibungen der bi
rey und unten machen wir jetzt die
beschreibung der 3 als ich mal hier und
das ist nicht ganz exakt
wenn ich jetzt sage
wenn ich jetzt sage enden es sei
gegenwärtig dann mache ich so einen
kleinen index mitgehen
dann folgt daraus wenn jetzt das
gegenwärtig ist dann folgt daraus dass m
vergangen ist und es folgt daraus dass
zukünftig ist
wenn ich hingegen jetzt sage ist
gegenwärtig dann folgt daraus was folgt
daraus denn wenn ich jetzt sage ihm ist
gegenwärtig was folgt daraus dass ich
muss ja eine heckkamera macht was draus
ja genau
in ist zukünftig und wo ist zu kaufen
jetzt können wir das noch weiterspielen
machen wir usa gegenwärtig was folgt
daraus
genau ns vergangenheit geben also
eigentlich müsste ich besser machen aber
noch ist vergangen sie sehen also es er
kam das völlig verschiedene aus je
nachdem alles einfach abhängig von
seinem index brauchen jetzt indizes und
oben ist völlig index frei das heißt es
in decsi kalisch ich habe ihn einmal zu
beginn des semesters bei spiel gebracht
wenn ich sagen heute liegt schnee in
münchen auf münchens straßen
wenn ich diesen satz die ersatz hat ein
war heizwert dieser satz kann wahr oder
falsch seien aber der wahrheit' wert
dieses satzes ändert sich je nachdem
wann ich ihn aussprechen also ich mach
das deswegen jetzt ja auch hier unten
hin heute in münchen bin ich den satz
jetzt also am praktisch am 15 februar um
12 uhr 3 und 5 43 jetzt das heißt ich
muss hier der index geben nämlich
praktisch als fünfter 5 2 2009 10
und zwar 1241 ist der index jetzt ist
der satz war
jetzt könnte es sein eine halbe stunde
später nämlich um 13 uhr 13 ist der satz
falsch derselbe satz familie aus gesagt
ist er falsch was müsste geschehen sein
dass dieser satz falsch ist
das müsste geschmolzen sein das heißt
natur noch es müsste hier plötzlich
irgendwie was passieren dass die
temperaturen in münchen so aufheizt dass
alle schnee schmilzt sonneneruption
keine ahnung kann ich ja nicht wissen
aber es könnte sein
wir können sie aber auch ganz anders
machen wir agieren hier einfach mal fünf
monate dazu wir machen dich 5205 siebten
und ich kann ihnen sagen am 15 7 wird in
münchen kein schnee liegen vielleicht an
manchen stellen wenn man im künstlich
herstellen aber es wird er wird nicht
liegen das heißt hier haben sie bei
solchen sätzen mit was ist das problem
warum ist dieser satz in seinem
wahrheit' wird abhängig von dem sprecher
oder genauer gesagt derzeit an dem er
geäußert systec und was ist der grund
der grund ist dass eben dieses heute
neben verschiedenen ist es heute ist
eben eine variable die abhängig ist von
der benutzung dieses satzes
da wo das an diesem zeitpunkt wo der
satz geäußert wird da ist eben heute
sozusagen
kennen sie die schildbürgerstreiche
haben sich schon was von den
schildbürgern gehört wer kennt die
schildbürger nicht ist also eine art
märchen und es gibt ein märchen dieser
schildbürger das besagt dass da im
mittelalter spielt es da wurde die stadt
angegriffen und die schildbürger hatten
eine ganz teure glocke glocke und dann
haben sie jetzt der fallen die glocke
erbeutet versenken wir sie im see damit
er sie nicht findet und wir holen sie
dann später wieder raus die glocke war
vielleicht jetzt nicht so groß aber es
im großen boot haben sie die glocke dann
auf den see gebracht und dann haben sich
überlegt ja wie machen wir das jetzt
dass wir sie wieder finden
er hatte ein schild bürger die daa ist
doch ganz klar wir machen einfach an dem
an der stelle des bootes wo wir die
glocke herunterlassen eine markierung
und dann finden wir es wieder und das
genau dasselbe wie hier verstehen sie
also dass ich hier sehe hier ist das
boot und da haben sie sich herunter
gelassen hat der schildbürger hier an
dieser stelle des bundes oben betrachtet
jetzt die markierung angebracht
warum klappt das nicht
warum wird man die glocke jetzt nie
wieder finden
sie lachen genau also diese markierung
am angebot ran da hat die man eben am
amboss rand eine markierung angebracht
also brandner an ihr in die wand da
haben wir die glocke runtergelassen wenn
das schiff jetzt wird sich da ist dann
ist die glocke ihr dasein
also es ist genau dasselbe jetzt eben
nur mit mit raum ja hier finden sie
nicht mehr dass also die schildbürger
haben nicht verstanden dass eben die
markierung am boot dann sinnlos ist wenn
eben das boot sicher bewegen kann man
muss ja wissen wie man wieder hin kommt
an die stelle wo man eben das boot mit
dieser markierung hatte es als ganz
ähnlich ist nicht genau dasselbe was
ganz ähnlich ok also das sind jetzt wir
sehen dass es jetzt praktisch er die
problematik und jetzt erstmal einfach
mal ein bisschen weiter halte er sagt
noch eine eine sache sagt er noch was
sagte jetzt sie in diesem zitat was
könnte man jetzt eigentlich annehmen
aber was ist nicht der fall
was was folgt also jetzt überlegen
philosophie hat es immer mit den ewigen
unveränderlichen dingen zu tun
demnach wäre doch eigentlich die b3
dasjenige was am fundamentalsten für die
zeit während also schauen sie mal fand
der menschen die das ding schon oft
early and later es könnte also es
eigentlich könnte man doch denken jetzt
das da oben das ist völlig unabhängig
von indizes als sollte doch eigentlich
die beschreibung der zeit nach der
bereits die eigentlich beschreiben
derzeit ausmachen aber so ist es nicht
sagt er
er sagt die unterscheiden zu den
vergangen gegenwärtig in zukunft die ist
eigentlich grundlegend ein
grundsätzlicher für die zeit aber es
gibt so ein neues buch eines physikers
und eines amerikanischen physikers die
wird es auch mal hier jetzt ein blinken
dieser minute wo sie das video dann auf
fast 10
und dieser physiker behauptet in seinem
buch dass der wechsel
das allerwichtigste ist der wechsel der
zeitwechsel und das eigentlich der idee
auch der physik entgegensteht weil die
physik ja eigentlich mit dem mit dem
gesetzen sich praktisch befassen soll
mit unveränderlichkeit er sagt nein die
naturgesetze sind auch sagen im zuge
einer evolution entstanden
das gibt es auch jetzt in der physik in
der spekulativen physik muss man
natürlich sagen weil die jetzt natürlich
nicht empirisch verifizieren
falsifiziert werden kann es geht um
physikalische modelle und auch in der
gegenwärtigen für sie gibt so ansetzen
dass man sagt wir brauchen dieses
veränderliche gerade auch um uns die
welt erklären zu können
ein kleiner exkurs also er sagt hier die
arbeit die ist eigentlich dass alle
entscheidendste für unser verständnis
der zeit und jetzt gehen wir mal weiter
vor den state of property shell station
running von gefahr passt mir past
present and future the future cities of
patients with plans for you too late for
this is the contents of apassionata
marko lenz als es gibt noch ereignisse
wir konnten uns auf das single pass
ischen alte tobi properly kulturelle
events i believe that i can be true
virtual
das single leben die universal-app
persischen in time is called am moment
halte da haben wir's noch je eine
position sind momente also ist ein
moment und wo unten und in und mgmg og
sind momente in der zeit die aber unter
dem gesichtspunkt des gegenwärtig
science betrachtet also die heidi hat
impliziert nicht nur eine ordnung wie es
die bereit sind die a3 die handheld noch
mehr informationen da braucht man immer
noch ein index dazu also die aare ist
eigentlich reicher dies reiche an
information als sdp ist da kommt eine
zusätzliche qualität hinzu zusätzlich
index nämlich ist das ganze jetzt gegen
werde zukünftig vergangen ja wir wissen
jetzt dass nach m ist also später als
eben und dass es früher also ist aber
ist es jetzt gegen werde vergangen oder
zukünftig das könnte ja auch sein dass
alle drei vergangen sind ja könnt ihr
auch sein
bin jetzt einfach nur mal die tal setzen
da kommt man in zukunft zusätzliche
information ins spiel
also hier haben wir jetzt die ganz
berühmte unterscheidung von a und b 3
zum ersten mal
wir haben sie immer implizit wer
verwendet in unseren beschreibungen der
jeweiligen philosophien aber hier haben
wir es jetzt also die arbeit ist eben
die drei derzeit die mit vergangen war
gegenwärtigkeit in zukunft zu tun hat
und die b3 geht einfach vom früheren zum
später als eine art von zeitliche
ordnung die aber nicht unter dem
gesichtspunkt der gegenwart
vergangenheit und der zukunft ist weil
sie nicht abhängig ist von einem
bestimmten gegenwärtigen bezugsbereit
ist nicht abhängig von einem index ik
lischen bezugs funktion nennt man das
termini wie heute oder morgen oder wie
hier das ist hier war der fehler der
schildbürger die haben den fehler des
index ik lischen here's gemacht das ist
wie jetzt hier ist ein index kalisch
bezug nahmen hier hier an diesem boot
hier aber wenn es eben das bot sich an
anderen orten findet dann ist hier eben
woanders genauso wie heute wenn es sich
einem anderen zeitpunkt befindet eben
auch eine andere information geht so
kann man das sagen dieses heute ist in
der zeit verschiebbar ich kann zu jedem
zeitpunkt heute sei an jedem tag heute
sagt ich kann jedem punkt des raumes
hier sein wenn ich da an etwas fest
mache dann bekomme ich das problem der
relativität ich müsste also genau
genommen bei dem sie im hätte ich einen
koordinator angeben müssen ich hätte
sagen müssen also hier ist das system
und es liegt eben so und so viel ist und
so und soviel ja also halt nord und sohn
also von einem bestimmten bezugspunkt
ich bräuchte einfach an fixen
bezugspunkt einen fixen bezugs punkt
habe ich nicht weil der bezugspunkt in
dem boot nicht fix ist weil das boot
sicher wiederum bewegt deswegen ist es
kein fixer bezugspunkt
das ist praktisch nur innerhalb des
systems aber nicht ganze system fix
das ein fehler dieser schildbürger und
ja also hier die ampera ganz wichtig
dass es die zentrale passage in diesem
ganzen aufsatz einfach sie wissen
vielleicht wenn sie wikipedia gelesen
haben dieser aufsatz mit seiner these
dass die zeit unwirklich sei ist nicht
mehr haltbar also das argument von max
eckart dass wir jetzt auch noch kurz
behandeln wollen das ist nicht haltbar
die unwirklichkeit derzeit aber der
aufsatz hat gerade dadurch bedeutung
gelangt dass er die unterscheidung von a
und b 3 gemacht hat also dafür ist der
aufsatz rühmt nicht für sein ergebnis
dass die zeit unglücklich sein dass
einfach nur die hilfsmittel die zu der
these führen sollten die sind diesem
aufsatz von bleibender philosophische
relevanz und nicht die thesen ist auch
schön dass man in der these falsch
liegen kann aber auf dem weg dorthin
einfach dann doch geschichte schreiben
kann für so viel geschichte schreiben
kann und es ist ja nicht nur da und
bereit die mit eckart ihr wirken möchte
unterschieden hat sagen auch noch die c
das wollen wir uns andere ein bisschen
anschauen twitter ist websense security
of time events schnittformen series s
world series ende das klima zu beginn
wird der tuner web surft ein eps von
links die series events in thalmässing
present and des autolebens wird
depressiv directly und paula der wendy's
in time memory fans wie beliebt wie
regarded as part of use and present
future dass die events of time as
observed bei us forces
er sagt gibt's als ich hier es ist
möglich dass wir zeit wahrnehmen was
auch immer jetzt observe hier genau
heils empfinden oder was weiß ich jetzt
nicht außer dass sie beide serien bildet
jetzt frage ich mich halt bei dieser
über dieser bei diesem zitat ist es
nicht schon so dass wenig allein nach
der ara jetzt zeit erfahren
da sich damit eigentlich die bereits
schon reduzieren kann
da sich die beere eigentlich auch schon
mit empfinden würde würden sie nicht
sagen also würden sie nicht sagen dass
ausbaus der a3 die beere folgt das in
der arbeit die bei analytisch enthalten
ist also wenn ich sage dass gegenwärtig
wo zukünftig und im vergangen ist folgt
daraus nicht dass hier
ja ja genau ich frage mich halt weniger
tage ist gegenwärtig
daraus folgt dann wenn dieses und o ist
zukünftig und ms vergangen folgt daraus
nicht das eben später als ms und früher
also ist was ja die information der bära
ist also ich meine er hat vielleicht
insofern recht als wir uns die arbeit
des gegenwärtigen nur immer so denken
können dass etwas früher und später ist
dass diese information immer in der
gegenwert gegenwart empfängt enthalten
ist aber mir scheint dass das irgendwie
ein bisschen anders dargestellt werden
können dass eben die bio serie 3 in der
3 enthalten ist jedenfalls wir haben
eben immer zwei informationen wenn wir
etwas 1 zukünftig vergangen oder
gegenwärtig einschätzen
dann haben wir damit immer auch die
information dass früher oder später in
bezug auf andere ereignisse wir haben
dass die bloße information dass früher
oder später eben nicht in die k index
kalisch relevant ist so dass wir diese
fälle hier nicht bekommen
hier an
also das ist also wichtiger sagt die
treten immer zu haben zugleich auf
selben zeit darf jetzt nichts sagen
das paradies ist elisabeth active e
mails distinction interviews im manthey
racing schon oft past present future ist
simpler konstellation am 1 real time
only contains a section of the beast das
team schon auf bentley geburt per sms it
really is but we might be able to think
of it s
es gebe die möglichkeit das sagt er hier
dass diese unterscheidungen gegenwärtig
vergangen und so künftig an die große
konstante illusion unseres geistes wäre
und dass die wirklichen wirkliche wesen
derzeit nur die unterscheidung der
baureihe dass früher oder später hat und
das ist tatsächlich auch wie wir schon
oft gesehen hatten hier die auffassung
der naturwissenschaften als ein
naturwissenschaftliches modell wird eben
nur die drei diebe hier in betracht
ziehen so eine information wie
gegenwärtig ist eigentlich für die
wissenschaft nicht zu relevant jetzt
kann man sich aber fragen
gut vielleicht mit der
relativitätstheorie das hatten sie ja
gebracht das könnte tatsächlich sein
dass die frage dessen was jetzt
gegenwärtig ist oder was jetzt vergangen
ist dass die b 3 in der der
relativitätstheorie wieder von bedeutung
wird ja und auch bei solchen fragen wie
zeitreisen und so die ja auch so ein
bisschen mit mit der relativitätstheorie
zu tun haben also ich meine
frage gibt es überlichtgeschwindigkeit
eine solche fragen die betreffen ja die
relativitätstheorie und da kommt dann
plötzlich schon die vergangenheit ein
spiel auf eine neue art also die physik
gegenwärtig tut als es ist eine
spannende frage inwiefern die
erkenntnisse der relativitätstheorie
nicht doch auch jetzt plötzlich eine
eine arbeit derzeit von bedeutung machen
und sie erinnern sich das problem in
albert einsteins spezielle
relativitätstheorie war die definiert
die definition der gleichzeitigkeit das
jetzt wie können wir ein verfahren
entwickelt das gesagt und jetzt haben
überall denselben zeitpunkt ja da hat
man sich einstellen viele gedanken
darüber gemacht als ich glaube in der
relativitätstheorie gespielt tatsächlich
auch die a3 eine größere rolle als sie
es in der normalen traditionellen physik
und der klassischen physik getan hat wo
eben nur frühere später relationen eine
bedeutung haben
des is not available supporters treibe
live cds also am
er sagt hier betonte noch einmal dass
die reihe
obwohl sie jetzt subjektiv ist also
obwohl hier im index kalisch einstellung
hier eine rolle spielen dass sie obwohl
das der fall ist
wesentlich wird die natur derzeit sind
also das gehört gerade zur zeit ihrer
definition dass sie in decsi kalisch
sensibel ist dass wir hier solche und
ich indizes hier anbringen müssen dass
zeit kurz gesagt verschließt das zeit
eben immer von der gegenwart in die
vergangenheit übergeht und von der
zukunft in die gegenwart geht wo bei
denen sich noch an den anfang dieses
textes wie hat er den zeitstrahl
definiert welche bewegung hat er hier
angesetzt werden uns doch mal ganz zu
beginn zwei fragen gestellt kommt die
zeit auf uns zu bewegen wir uns oder
kommt die zeit von der vergangenheit in
die zukunft
was sagt ihr hier
gehen wir mal zurück
die hat also
dieses zitat
hier sagt das ganz eindeutig und zwar
wieder metaphorisch running von fast
rührend er vertritt die auffassung dass
die zeit sich von der vergangenheit in
die zukunft gelegt dass die also von
hinten nach vorne läuft und nicht dass
sie es sein dass die zukunft auf uns
zukommt und durch uns durchläuft das
waren also diese zwei modelle die wir
hier unterschieden hatten zu beginn ist
eigentlich irrelevant weil es aufs selbe
hinaus läuft aber das ist doch mal
interessant dass ich ja sagt
ok weiter gehts advertiser postuliert
mit teamworx change apotheke oder sing
in die max ist an change a time but then
we ask what we were to friend moments of
time on the origin of time for which das
singen wars 2 findet wie made it remains
the wild things change the universe in
which the single ever change including
des sports auf der kann also ganz
wichtig wieder hier zeitbedarf des endes
der veränderung und das ist jetzt wieder
die zeit bedarf einer ordnung des
veränderns interessante sätze
metaphysische aussage letzter satz und
universe in which in affing what ever
change would be a time square da wo kein
wandel ist da auch keine zeit
ja ja halt er hat offensichtlich ja das
interessant also weil bei kant es ist ja
so bekannt unterliegen ja subjekte
eigentlich nicht derzeit also im
wesentlichen lernen also intelligente
wesen unsere kant unterscheide zwischen
dem hormon oben und homo phänomen und
dem menschen als bloß intelligentes
wesen und als empirisch zugängliches
wesen und eigentlich ist der mensch eben
ein nominales wesen als ein reines
vernunft wesen jedenfalls ganz
moralischer sicht und die zeit ist etwas
was das objekt wie ich schon sagte
mitbringt obwohl die weite des
mitbringen es jetzt sehr sehr vage ist
und zu missverständnissen und lebt aber
sie ist eine bedingung der möglichkeit
und hier scheint er jetzt ihr so eine
art von objekt iwis tische zeit
anzusetzen die unabhängig vom subjekt
ist in diesem satz
interessant ja es gibt doch dieses
modell des jungstars
das kennen sie also dieses dieser dieser
ewigen gegenwart
dass aber auch ein zeitliches modell das
scheint jetzt hier nicht zu
berücksichtigt das haben wir es in
diesem seminar nicht behandelt also
diesen diese permanent des guten was der
gegenwart und das wäre ein zeitliches
universum
die frage ist halt wie man sich das
vorstellt dieses verweilen des
augenblicks der ewige augenblick so
könnte man sagen ist ja die begriffliche
widerspruch im augenblick ist halt als
solche nur ein moment das vorübergeht
der vom parkett
aber das gibt eben jetzt moment des
jungstars das jetzt stehen des stehen
bleiben und das ist eben nicht so zu
verstehen dass der zeiger der uhr stehen
bleibt dass der zeiger der uhr in der
zeit stehen bleibt
anders das stehenbleiben selbst zeitlich
ist und nicht das aufhören derzeit all
das ist natürlich schwer sich
vorzustellen
also unsere kleine gegenwart ewige
gegenwart kann man sich überlegen was
das eher vorteile bietet ich denke dass
das vielleicht die wirklichkeit eines
ewigen wesens beschreibt also wenn man
jetzt metaphysische überlegungen
anstellt dass man sich das so vorstellen
müsste und das für alle gewesen
diese index die qualität nicht gilt
sondern müsste man sie jetzt fragen ob
dann überhaupt die b34 ewig gewesen gilt
könnte schon sein könnte schon sein dass
alles seine ordnung hat aber dass es
eben nicht um über diese intec indizes
gegenseitig weiter differenziert bei ist
dass das wegfällt
also spannende frage ich sage jetzt
nicht vielleicht von der hausarbeit aber
mal für einen gedankengang bei ihnen
selbst wie müsste ein ewiges wesen
zeitempfinden oder zeit erleben am konto
sagen es gibt keine zeit für ein ewiges
lesen okay aber wenn es die gäbe würde
ein ewiges wesen zeit erleben das ist
eine spannende frage ja wir reden ja nur
von uns endlich ein wesen also ein
unsterbliches ws wie würde das zeit
leben
es würde sicherlich zeit erleben so das
etwas früher oder später ist und
vielleicht auch als vergangen und
zukünftig aber vielleicht ändert sich
auch etwas dran
das können sich mal selbst will ich
würde aber nicht von der hausarbeit
jeweils zu kompliziert ist so dann lesen
wir oder haben sie noch eine frage dazu
im letzten punkt sonst lesen wir einfach
mal weiter
change without the departed ist ingrid
of press and future das notarielle can
change and reality what is changing
hier sagt er
er fragt das jedenfalls er fragt das
jetzt mal ist es ja nur eine frage also
fragt jetzt hier wenn eine b3 ohne eine
arbeit konzentrieren kann
dann muss eine veränderung möglich sein
ohne eine a
es ist nun einmal so eine hypothese mal
weiter eine gute frage
von change konsistent effekte change
also fragt sich jetzt können wir uns
eine zeit an zeitlauf vorstellen könnten
wir das sagen in dem eine beere ohne
eine rein
ein veränderung bewegte
dann können wir uns veränderungen ohne
diarra denken das ist die frage
ja ja genau der physik brauchen wir
keine keine gegenwarts besitzt keinen
kein index wir brauchen nicht diesen
zeiten ja das möchte er mit anderen war
auch nicht eine festlegung wo jetzt
gegenwart ist also das sind praktisch
gegen das können natürlich auch
vergangenheit indikatoren sein dass hier
habe ich schreibe jetzt einfach mal
gegenwarts indikator gegenwarts
indikator habe nur mal ein beispiel ist
legen wir uns in die karten
hier ist jetzt gegenwart hier dieses
indikator meinte sexy kalisch indikator
das ist dasselbe wie heute ist einfach
abhängig vom zeitpunkt wo ich das wort
in den mund nehmen genauso wie hier
das problem ist dieser index gibt dieser
indikatoren dass die nicht fix sind weil
unter ihnen was weg läuft also
indikatoren wie heute wie jetzt da wo
ich jetzt sage ist es jetzt schon
vergangen ja also das jetzt ist sondern
hinweis wir müssen die hinweise so
vorstellen da drücken sie auf was drauf
sie zeigen auf was drauf sage jetzt aber
die wand läuft vorbei so müssen sie das
vorstellen jetzt und die wand läuft
vorbei wie seine fließband bei einem ort
geht das bei mord kann ich hier sagen
unter umständen aber bei den boots
beispiel nicht weil sich daher das boot
dann noch verändern weil sie müssen sich
so verstellen jetzt und die die wand
läuft bei dann ist jeder jetzt
fingerzeig anders jetzt nennen
die postbank geht sagte er es ist in
postbauer ein event can never seems to
be an event ich kenne never get out of
any time service in which it once sfn
ist allen anderen mbit usb and has
always been to end lennart nms
installations öle und leder permanent es
bei press and ipod ist i'm ist
konstatiert barcelona will always have
heard a series and has had one that it
has always been an event and camping
ossis tobias h
was also ist muss auch nach der 3
immer schon ein ereignis sein und kann
nicht entstanden sein
hier ist
das problem ist nach der b 3 ist im in-
und o sind immer schon ereignisse die
praktisch als solche gar nicht entstehen
also der wandel vollzieht sich jetzt
nicht in den einzelnen ereignisse von
der wandel vollzieht sich zwischen den
verschiedenen ereignissen also der
wandel liegt nicht darin dass es
entsteht weil im ist als ereignis schon
entstanden ein ereignis ohne standen sie
sein ist gar nicht möglich
zum wandel tritt einfach im übergang von
zwei ereignissen auf der wandel betrifft
nicht ein einzelnes ereignis sind die
relation von ereignissen
aha
[Musik]
und interessant ist nach der biere sind
immer ereignisse und werden die aufhören
ereignisse gewesen zu sein
ja genau richtig sehr gut das sind guter
punkt genau also deswegen nennt man auch
die b3 die presse die idealistische sich
journalistische sicht so als ob eben
alles ausgebreitet liegt das können wir
natürlich bei der arie eigentlich nicht
tun
wir sehen also die a3 wenn ich die
arbeit hier so auf die bären abbilde
mache ich fehler weil wenn ich sage wenn
ich jetzt diesen fall hier wähle dann
dürfte er gar nicht mehr sein
verstehen sie also wenn ich mich jetzt
entscheide in diese reihe dann hat im
aufgehört zu existieren und wo ist noch
nicht ich heiße ich müsste die das
müsste ich zum beispiel gestrichelt
machen so also dem sinne dass es noch
kommt und das genauso oder irgendwie
anders
das ist nicht mehr ist und wir können
uns damit behelfen indem wir das eben
also grafisch abbilden dem wir eben in
den index machen und dann ebenso
logische folgerung beziehung daraus
machen daraus wurde aber sie habe völlig
recht das heißt ich muss die ich muss
die wirklich mir freundlich die muss die
wirklich als alle drei gegenwärtig
ansehen und das ist guter punkt weil
damit heben wir sie eigentlich die
gegenwart hinein
wir nehmen ihnen den aspekt des
zukünftigen gegenwert in den vergangen
wenn wir sagen letztendlich sind alle
gegenwärtig also wir nehmen ihn
eigentlich ein aspekt des vergangenen
und zukünftigen wir behandeln sie als
gegenwärtig als gegenwärtig oder als
präsent in einer gewissen gewissen
ordnung aber die ordnung ist eben nicht
nur räumlich das ist eben noch wichtig
glaube ich sie ist nicht nur räumlich
sondern sie ist zeitlich neben halt dass
wir sagen früher oder später und bei
einer räumlichen ordnung wäre das eben
mehr oder entfernte oder so aber wir
sehen dieses nähe oder entfernt hat das
verbindet man auch mit blick auf zeit
punkte dieser zeitpunkt ist nah er narrt
der zeitpunkt naht das aber eine
räumliche metaphern nah und fern sind
räumliche etappen ein neuer räumliche
begriffe und nicht bezeichnen
also wir neigen aber dazu glaube ich in
der b3 tatsächlich ist eine
verheimlichung vorzunehmen
das ist richtig aber dennoch muss man
darauf bestehen dass früher also das
prädikat früher früher und später dass
die eben unterschieden sind von mehr
mehr versus ferner das ist ganz wichtig
wir müssen früher wäre das späte ganz
strikt unterscheiden zwischen nähe und
ferne nähe und ferne sind rein sind
zeitlose prädikate und früher oder
später sind zeitgebunden prädikat also
die implizieren die oberen die
implizieren dass derzeit vorliegen muss
auch wenn wenn auch eben nur im rat im
sinne der b 3 aber sie implizieren zeit
sie setzten zeit voraus während näher
und ferner geben das nicht tut
deswegen können wir nicht
drei überführen in der rede weise von
mehr oder ferner also wenn ich jetzt
sage aniston er als m
dann würde ich das nicht eigentlich tun
können dann würde ich nicht mehr meine
zeit reihe sprechen ja vielleicht würde
ich so dann über eine drei sprechen
können wir kommen jetzt noch zu zäh es
könnte also sein dass wir mit mehr und
ferner mit diesen prädikaten hier über
die cad sprechen können die wir noch gar
nicht jetzt hier gesehen haben deswegen
lesen wir mal ein bisschen weiter das
jetzt glaube ich ein bisschen
wiederholung immer schauen
wo haben wir die cd jetzt hier springe
mal ein bisschen
das ist vielleicht noch wichtiges fazit
with no change and consequently bbc
research business edition for time since
time interessante these interessante
these also sagt sie sagten ja das ist
praktisch so eine art von präsent ist
ische sicht die bereiche da habe ich gar
kein wandels und wir haben nur so früher
oder später relation wir kommen bekommen
als nur wandel im sinne des ereignis ist
jetzt nicht mehr wenn wir es gestrichelt
machen können nur dann haben wir wandeln
wenn wir diese alternative alternierende
weil sie haben und das jetzt eben gerade
die arbeit voraus wandel sagt er hätten
wir eben nicht nur auf der b3 weil da
haben wir so wie sie richtig sagen seine
räumlichen oder ist die
vergegenwärtigung wirbt drei sachen und
sie sind ja alle präsent sind ja nur in
einer gewissen logik voneinander
getrennt wir haben nicht den
eigentlichen bundle darin beschrieben
also schau mal hier jetzt jetzt kommen
wir noch am schluss zu der verein hat
das notfall etwas abstrakter
determination of the series von time we
shall have no series live tutor der ist
sc riessersee ist auf der permanent
relations gewonnen aber auf toast
realities wird in time events and the
combination of this series with a
determination switch schiffsteil dies
alles die reset us colleges service is
not tempelhof change battaglia nordens
heaven oder das c in die order auf npd
der von nord in die order nnp nnp von
enya possible but that i had spotted
this and change denn die order auf der
ladies of diabetes und parlament los
angeles which ditched into reality is
only one change dann kam im bett
relations of the series become nations
of pearl and later and sweet bekam pcs
sowie verhalten sie jetzt a b und c
zueinander das ist jetzt noch eine ganz
spannende frage
die wir hier behandeln wollen vielleicht
sagt er auch noch ein bisschen was im
nächsten zitat aber wir könnten auch mal
hier bleiben ja wir müssen das nächste
auch noch lesen aber jetzt schauen wir
erstmal was sagt er jetzt hier in diesem
zitat
also gehen sie beim ersten erster satz
wenn wir also abziehen abstract die
determination of the series
wenn wir also von der zeit die
eigenschaft des vergangenen
gegenwärtigen zukünftig wegnehmen dann
folgt daraus dass folgte haus nicht dass
nichts mehr übrig bliebe
es gibt da eine reihe von permanenten
relationen verhältnissen zueinander von
wirklichkeiten die in der zeit
ereignisse sind und die verbindung die
kombination dieser rein
diese rein mit der determination aller
bestimmtheit vergangen gegen die zukunft
ermöglicht eure macht zeit wirklich aber
diese cd ist jetzt nicht zeitlich da sie
keinen wandel impliziert sondern nur
eine ordnung
jetzt muss man sich doch fragen ist es
dann aber was ist dann der unterschied
von der bzb also das ist natürlich die
cer ein natürlich nicht die wahrheit ist
das ist klar weil die arbeit immer dem
gesichtspunkt des gegenwärtig
vergangenen und zukünftigen spieler aber
was ist denn bitte schön der unterschied
zur wehr
bei dem er das gegenwärtig und so fehlt
was ist jetzt der unterschied haben sie
eine idee sagt im gegensatz zu jetzt
implizit ist die cd nicht zeitlich alles
dürfen jetzt nicht solche prädikate
darin vorkommen wie früher oder später
zeitlichen senden
es steht sowieso grundsätzlicher plan
von ereignissen aber sozusagen
relationen erst genau sowas aber es ist
eben nicht zeitlich das kann man nun
dazu sagen genau
und deswegen war das von mir nicht ganz
korrekt dass ich das jetzt dass die
baureihe so charakterisiert hat weil
damit eben nicht zeitlichkeit impliziert
ist dass damit habe ich eigentlich die
cd vorgestellt eigentlich ja
also man könnte sich das vielleicht so
vorstellen wie so ein zahlen strahlen
wieso einzahlen stralsund kontinuum von
zahlen
alle zahlen sind geordnet aber zahlen
sie nicht zeitlich dort ja
doch denke ich schon doch doch glaube
ich schon
würde es impliziert oder wäre nicht
widerspricht oder was würden sie sagen
ja ok kausal wäre schon sehr sehr stark
aber es ist qualität wäre ein möglicher
fall dieser ordnung ist nicht zeit nicht
nur natürlich kann man sich jetzt fragen
riesen thema setzt kausalität nicht
immer zeitlichkeit voraus anderes thema
aber denken sie noch einmal zurück an
die bisher behandelten positionen
richard denker hatte denn jetzt gerade
behauptet dass die zeit aus der c reihe
entspringt als wir hat jetzt genau den
entgegengesetzten weg beschritten
also mit eckart sagt ja wenn wir alles
abstrahieren von der a3 alle
zeitlichkeit dann kommen wir zu der zeit
vor jetzt gibt es aber ein denke du
sagst hinein wie kommen von der zu der
zeit nur über die cdu überhaupt die zeit
ist so eine art von epi phänomene was
auch immer der c3 picasso leibnitz hatte
doch gesagt die zeit kommt ihr es dann
ins spiel wenn wir seine ordnung haben
so relationen haben wir hatten die da
wir hatten die kausal bestimmt aber es
muss nicht kausal sein dass praktisch
hier glaube ich so ein bisschen leibnitz
leibnitz hätte seine c3 eigentlich der
zeit da wir bis da wir eben zu beginn
des semesters nur die a und die b 3 1
geführt hatten konnten wir jetzt
leibnitz nicht damit klassifizieren aber
er wäre vielleicht am ehesten als sehr
ein theoretiker zu verstehen natürlich
einem anderen sinne als es jetzt mit
tiger tour wird er halt die cd als das
fundament ansehen und hier ist die zwei
die letzte abstraktionsebene subtraktion
geben derzeit das was eben übrig bleibt
wenn man alles seitliche wegnimmt dann
bleibt halt nur noch eine ordnung
und ich glaube er bringt nicht ohne
grund das alphabet weil die ordnung der
buchstaben alphabet ist halt nicht
zeitlich ist vielleicht nicht ganz so
gut es sollte vielleicht lieber sagen
3456 weil die folge des alphabets eher
willkürlich ist ich könnte ja auch das
alphabet anders laufen lassen von z nach
a ist nicht notwendig es sollte
vielleicht eher sagen sondern 12345 weil
da eben auch so eine gewisse logische
beziehung dazwischen ist da ist die
ordnung glaube ich noch ein bisschen
besser ausgedrückt
wobei die frage natürlich die ist ob
jetzt zahlen 1 2 3 4 5 in ihrer abfolge
noch ordnung genauso zu verstehen sind
wir einfach nur bestimmte positionen mal
zahlen haben ja zueinander applikations
verhältnis und das alphabet hat sondern
die buchstaben des alphabets in ihrer
ordnung haben keine implikationen
verhältnis zueinander
ja also z schließt nicht irgendwie b in
sich ein während acht eben die 24 mal in
sich schließen dass hat aristoteles
gezeigt dass also die die zahlen anders
gestuft sind als es andere ordnung
deswegen ist es vielleicht richtig dass
er hier nicht die zahlen bringen aber
das ist jetzt ein anderes thema
also zahlen sind inklusions
verhältnissen entschließen sich ein und
solche ordnung jetzt nicht unbedingt das
was die die bloße logische ordnung nicht
weiter change the direction does not
intend to but it can run pee wee ellis
and peace ladies latest als bio energie
ist earl ist nm ist der is nothing aber
in the series and effect of change to
date on which will be
jetzt brauchen wir noch
weiteren punkt haben wir noch was sagte
jetzt hier
warum braucht als was fehlt jetzt der c3
der cdu fehlt jetzt eine richtung
es ist nur eine ordnung und ich glaube
das macht es nochmals sehr sehr deutlich
den unterschied so behre wir hatten uns
hier gefragt ist nicht frei und sehr
eigentlich dasselbe wenn wir
abstrahieren von den aspekte gegenwärtig
keinen zeigt er nein
die cd ist nicht zeitlich sg ch ist nur
eine logische relation okay das ist gut
und er bringt jetzt den grund der grund
ist also der haben es den grund was
unterscheidet die b 3 von der cd
er bringt jetzt dieses beispiel pnm oder
im op also die serie in ihrer logischen
ordnung kann eben auf zwei weisen
durchlaufen werden kann so durchlaufen
werden also mlp als praktisch die c3 die
chmp oder das gegenteil nämlich op
machen sonst durch drüber die strecke
oder pro mms
das wäre alles möglich für die ca
während die bsm haben in der richtung
etc lässt sich auf zwei weisen
durchlaufen weil ja nur die abfolge der
ereignisse die ordnung nicht die abfolge
ich darf gar nicht sagen wie abscheulich
darf nur sagen die ordnung also nur das
verhältnis der sachen drunter ist die
frage wenn ich jetzt halt sage ist
größer als im kann ich dann noch so
durchlaufen
aber eigentlich schon
com
sieht es ähnlich oder würde das anders
sehen geben nochmal also reine sagt im
zweiten satz change mast einer party
oder direction und die c serie die
dritte zeile bestimmt die ordnung aber
nicht die richtung
und die zählerei bestimmt nicht welche
reihenfolge leben gelaufen werden muss
so muss man sich das eben vorstand die
cdu stimmt nicht
die richtung der des ablaufs
genau und das bei bedarf eben eine
richtung und die richtung ist eben nicht
vorgegeben in der 2
die richtung des durchlaufen deswegen
denke ich dachte ich jetzt gerade so ein
bisschen dran ist es jetzt ein bisschen
schwierig mit diesen größer als weil
dass er eine gewisse richtung vorgibt
aber es könnte einfach nur bedeuten es
kommt halt her
genau also richtig genau also man müsste
halt man könnte das auch genau eben
umdrehen hier die sachen dann wäre es
die reihe als die ziele gibt keine
richtung des durchlaufen zuvor
offensichtlich ja es ist einfach nur
eine ordnung dass also man kann sich das
so vorstellen dass diese ereignisse
nebeneinander sind so müsste man es
sagen ja also die c3 würde nur sagen
dass so kann man glaube ich sagen dass
es in der mitte von m und o ist dass
diese informationen wären nur ein
erzähler enthalten das in der mitte von
ihm und wo es diese information ist mir
zu enthalten
aus dieser information dass in der mitte
zwischen es folgt aber auch das mm in
der mitte von tim ist
also wenn ich jetzt mal logisch wenn
oder n ist in der mitte gekommen wie
soll das erst mal formalisieren das in
der
das bräuchte man irgendwie ein zeichen
warum einfach mal das hier
wie das soll einfach heißen es in der
mitte von m
dann ist das genau dasselbe wie wenn es
der mitte von und m
ich kann hier in der klammer ich kann
das beliebig umdrehen würde würden sie
mir zustimmen
genau ich kann genau ich kann alles
praktisch soll das nicht dass das eine
dreistellige relation das ist logisch
eine dreistellige relation also so
müsste man das sagen
genau das ist das dreistöckige relation
ja also eben entsteht in der relation
das in der mitte science von m und o
und das kann ich eben auf zwei ist kann
ich ganz logisch auf zwei verschiedene
weisen ausdrücken und damit hammers weil
die bh erlaubt es nicht diese zwei hier
um zu drehen
die sensitive für die richtung da geht
nur einfach davon
und die c3 erlaubt eben zwei fälle die
dreistellige relation ist eben auf zwei
weisen beschreibbar
ich glaube da so ergibt es jetzt in als
es nicht ganz leicht sich vorzustellen
die cd ist nicht ganz leicht
jetzt gehen wir noch ein bisschen vor
also das lesen aber als teenager scott
tempel has no direction of its a series
of the first encounter das beispiel
finde ich ganz so gut wie unseres weil
er sagt jetzt klar wir bleiben wird
werden diese rey gerecht auch wir werden
diese recht wenn wir als auch rückwärts
zählen ja die rai bleibt dieselbe
aber indem man sagt rückwärts karte ja
schon eingestanden das ist eine andere
ordnung jetzt stattgefunden hat und wir
haben es glaube ich mit dieser
dreistellige relation besser gezeigt
weil wir darin gar keine ordnung schon
vorausgesetzt
bei den quads hatte herr beck kurz
gesagt nee das sagt jetzt nicht doch
beck beckord damit hat er eigentlich
implizit schon eine
3 in richtung eingezogen ist eigentlich
kein gutes beispiel
beck wort sagt da gibt's schon da hat er
schon die reihe um getrennte also wir
haben das besser gezeigt
und genau hier gibt es noch ein paar
beschreibung und jetzt bringt er hier
noch ein als jetzt kommt er jetzt eine
art konklusion hsbc 67 improving wird
der can be no time that remains to prove
that ist der der fatah im klartext ist
das wird in the time is not real time
since it that way in which can be real
ist bei existieren
moments of time attack and realities wie
sieht auf dem foto dpa past present
future charakteristik maybe the election
of quality of pop morris interview mit
cnn warf akon tradition als er versuchte
zu zeigen dass wir wenn wir die ahr
rhein die entweder als ereignisse oder
als relationen ansehen sie ein
ein widerspruch enthalten
dieses zitat noch zum schluss dass first
is only one to feature relations can be
on demand for moment die amateur must be
some think outside vor dem release of
the series changing relations innovation
of terms for the times they are change
to events exactly in the same place in
des teams ihres relativ luciana diniz
bevor details of them is taking place
and wenn die arminia ist sofort relation
of momence change agent iftar moments of
time alter wie das tablet realities from
the plans mitschleppen in dem green an
event and moment ist an werra event ist
in diesem moment in the future the
present and in the past present future
inkompatibel determination event must go
on the fish & chips in kombination mit
easy series of time for time swf 10 in
wolfs change and the change we can't get
enough youtube präsent
also wird praktisch damit zeigen dass
die arbeit in sich widersprüchlich ist
warum ist sie in sich widersprüchlich
was ist der grundgedanke haben sie eine
idee was könnte das problem sein der a3
mit relationen
das problem ist so viel will ich nur
noch kurz am ende sagen ich werde die
zusammenfassung dann noch ein bisschen
ausführlich begründen dass wir eben das
problem in der arbeit haben das hier
eigentlich immer schon nur ein ereignis
existiert zur selben zeit wir haben
immer nur den jetzigen gegenwärtigen
moment als existenz m und o wenn jetzt
wenn die gegenwart ist existieren nicht
mehr
eigentlich so wie sie es auf der b3 tun
also wir haben ein problem hier auf der
a3 wirkliche relationen herzustellen war
ja gar keine relation mehr zustande
gebracht werden kann man ja
gegenwärtiges nur ist und vergangenes
und zukünftiges nicht mehr
das ist so ein bisschen das problem was
er hier eben anbringt und er sagt
deswegen kann eigentlich zeit wandelt
gar nicht existieren weil wir zu sagen
keine relation herstellen können bei
relation er immerzu existierenden
entitäten hergestellt werden muss
das ist so ein bisschen das argument
jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen ist
es überzeugend das könnten sie zum
beispiel an hausarbeit machen als ich
finde allein auch schon die beschreibung
der b&c beim eckert ist auch ein
spannendes hausarbeit thema das noch
richtig logisch sauber hinzubekommen
wir sind jetzt auch wirklich zeitlich
überzeit redend am ende angelangt dass
es die letzte sitzung des semesters
denen sie wie gesagt fragen haben
schreiben sie mir per e-mail kommen sie
eine sprechstunde wird auch noch weitere
sprechstunden termine ankündigen
sie bekommen von mir auch noch alle
zusammenfassungen gebündelt zugeschickt
sind jetzt fast 30 zeiten das wird die
basis eines neuen buches werden
aber da ist noch ein bisschen hinter
möchte ich erst noch ihre ideen in ihrem
hause balken mit plagiator ish
einfließen
dann wünsche ich ihnen noch schöne
semesterferien